hi there this is me again steve goffman
and of course i'm very happy to have a
special guest richard simcott i don't
know if he needs an introduction
to those of us in the
language learning community he is one of
the
gurus
he doesn't want to admit how many
languages he speaks but it's got to be
many times more than i do
and he speaks them very well
and so he's a very well-known
polyglot and i would like to ask him
some questions richard is that okay for
having me well i'm very pleased to have
you
and uh what i want to ask is this
basically uh there are polyglots well
known within our community
uh and there are many things that we
have in common in terms of our methods
and our attitudes but there also are
differences yeah
and so i'm a very much input-based kind
of learner and then i get to a point
where i want to speak but i don't go to
school okay
i have for french
and then for chinese but all the other
languages no
i understand that you actually enjoy
going to language class so i wanted to
ask you about your method of learning
which i should say has been very
successful obviously because you speak a
lot of languages very well
and
what you think is important and what is
the role of the language class
okay so
yeah it is interesting that quite a lot
of people say that they don't use
language classes or they they find them
unhelpful or too slow i think finding
the right language class is really
important
so i would never say that i do it all
the time for every language of course
right possible right um but if there is
a language class i'm very social animal
right i love the interaction with the
people
i love the things i learned from them so
it's not a one-on-one class no no no i
go to a group if possible so for example
when i moved to
skopje where
i now live
in the republic of macedonia i wanted to
learn turkish because it's one of the
main languages that's spoken in the city
and i went to the
uno semre institute in centro scopia
with a group of people who wanted to
learn turkish within on an intensive
course right so that at least i wouldn't
feel that i was going very slowly
and i actually really enjoyed it because
i got insights into
because they were all from local
uh people macedonia yeah i was getting
input from them from how they saw the
turkish language affect their own
language
they were sharing and of course you
speak macedonians yeah of course yeah so
the course was only in masada well the
course was supposed to be just in target
language in turkish right but if there
were ever any explanations needed
they would be given in macedonia right
and that wasn't a problem so i was sort
of doing the sort of outside class we
tell a chat in macedonia and or whatever
um but i found that really interesting
and how many hours a day or how many
times a week and it's 16 hours a week
oh that's a lot yeah yeah and was that
the sum total of your effort or did you
then go home and do other things no i
mean you always use it so i i tend to
practice as much as possible so i'd find
and seek out turkish speakers in town
and practice it with them and i'd listen
to bits of things on on tv turkish news
or whatever i could find right and you
know i believe as well in a lot of
inputs so right you need a lot of um
sort of time to sort of exposure to the
language right not just
one source and is your input primarily
than audio input because you're talking
to people and they're kind of the
language is coming back at you or did
you also read in turkish so in the bit i
mean in the beginning
the the reading you can do is limited of
course yes but um yeah i do i do
different things so
now for example with turkish i may i may
read subtitles i might have a program
running english right when they have the
subtitles in turkish or i may watch
something in turkish have subtitles in
in macedonia or
in in serbian or in another language
that i speak
um well right
and that way i find that it just sort of
keeps things interesting
but the classes really were fundamental
to bringing me on because i had very
definite goals
i was taken out of my comfort zone which
i think sometimes as a language learner
especially if you're autodidactic
you you can you can look so much in on
yourself
that you will only learn things that
you're really interested in right but
when you have a conversation with a
language partner
of course you you have to there's a
sharing right to go on they might
mention things that you've never heard
of
things that you're not interested in
right so the language class i found
because you had different personalities
right helped to really bring those
things out right now of course you were
in macedonia
learning turkish which is a language
that is spoken there
now what if you're learning a language
or have you been in a situation where
you are learning a language where there
are no no speakers of the language
locally uh there may not even be courses
offered locally uh what do you do then
then normally what i do is get a book i
like course books i like to read through
and get an idea of the language so
in that way i guess i may be a more
typical polyglot because i think a lot
of polyglots do tend to do that kind of
thing they'll just get a book and work
through it as though they were in class
but what i will normally do is
supplement that with um a teacher online
so from italki
or find
a speaker
and i will um
maybe not always use the book exactly as
it's prescribed i would read a dialogue
and then i would make that dialogue
relevant to my own life
so when i was learning norwegian for a
trip to norway
i took the teach yourself a norwegian
book
i
read it over the course of about a month
and then each lesson with my teacher i
meet once a week and i tell her the unit
i'd studied to talk about what happened
this is online this is it online yeah
yeah talk about the what happened in the
book what happens with the the
characters in the book and then say but
in my life
this is what happened to me
so i'd make it relevant to myself right
and then i went to norway and practiced
with people and
chatted away so yeah it's
but still there's an element of teaching
there because you're sort of you're
making up your own teacher environment
yeah no and uh you know i certainly have
shared that experience for example with
check where i study check on my own but
with the goal of going to prague to
interact with people and activate it and
also of course i use online tutors
and try to
get them to talk about for example say
lessons that i'm studying
you know a link and whatever and so it
is similar to that extent although i'm i
tend
i do use teach yourself as a place to
get started in the language exactly but
then i tried to get into a range of you
know content uh you know that i can work
but
um
to what extent do you think the
polyglots how much of their learning
methodology is common and to what extent
do they have sort of their own
individual
approaches i think many people have very
different approaches
but they're the one thing that they they
really have in common is
the
sort of dyna so i guess motivation it
sounds a bit right that's right i guess
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's there
yeah but it's um
it is important because they have the
motivation from the general um and very
concentrated interest
right it's very focused interest in
right in learning it and
they question language i think
so you know if you i guess you would
maybe do this as well but if you walk
down the street yes you've been learning
czech you walk down the street in prague
you see a word you don't know
and what do you do do you even look at
it and think about it no no just ignore
it
so even then maybe maybe that it's still
different i don't know
let's put it this way i enjoy the fact
that i'm walking down the street and i
can read
uh certain things and
whatever i can read in check i'm very
happy about if i can't read the word or
don't know what it means i just i just
ignore it in that scenario like if i'm
learning on link i'm looking the word up
and i'm saving it and all that kind of
stuff but if i'm out there
even if i'm out with people and they're
using words that i don't know i don't uh
i don't worry about it no i guess
focusing on sort of a random word maybe
not be the example i'm looking for it
would be something i know that i'm going
to pass every day or i see
constantly yeah if i see it more often i
might worry about it yeah yeah so for
example in i was i was learning latvian
and i went to riga right and i kept
saying the word jedi and i was like what
the hell's this word and i hadn't
learned it in my in any of the texts i
learned it was actually just clothes
yeah but i looked it up on my mobile
phone found out the word and then every
day i would go past and i would keep
saying and it would remind me right you
know of the word yeah
certainly but i think in the total
number of words that i learn
the number of words that sort of stick
out like a sore thumb and bother you and
what does that mean and stuff they're
not that many if there's 50 there's 50.
it's not like thousands
no no no i think the context of the
words is really important you know how
you learn them where you learn them yeah
in which words go together yeah you know
yeah um you know if you're learning
english and you learn the word quench
right there's no point learning the word
quench on its own quench your thirst
right exactly yeah
it's it's a set phrase almost uh
i think we we tend to develop sort of
the the habit or the experience of being
able to sort of latch onto these these
phrases
uh so to wrap it up then i think though
that uh
the nice thing about this conference is
that uh different people have learned a
different number of languages and speak
them i mean there are some people here
who speak too yeah and and want to
almost apologize for the fact that they
only speak english language they
shouldn't and everybody is very
supportive and and respectful of the
fact that people dif people have
different approaches but the same goal
exactly not even the same goal some
people want to become totally fluent
some people just want to have an
understanding of the language and that's
all fine and so um you know the next
time there's a polyglot gathering near
you and the next one is enriquez
and what are the dates there it's the
end of october so 27 29th of october
okay and uh richard is also sort of the
originator of these polyglot gatherings
or conferences because the first one was
in
budapest budapest was the first one what
year was actually kindly supported yes
that was five years ago now five years
ago and then you've had it in
thessaloniki yes and there's there's
another it's called called the gathering
which was in berlin and then in
bratislava and now we have here
and i
at some level we all hope that uh
you know what what i call the polyglot
ghetto which is all the cleaners that
somehow this will expand into the
broader community and encourage people
to learn languages and i would encourage
you to participate in any polyglot
conference gathering that may be taking
place near you yeah i think it's
infectious you know the whole the
environment is infectious people uh are
genuinely very open
and whether you're on your first or your
21st language it doesn't really matter
exactly and you we all learn from each
other
you know yep absolutely and we don't
judge each other
okay bye bye
[Music]
you